مرحبًا أيها الضابط أوسكار ، لماذا لا نعود
إلى هنا ، سأعود سريعًا
حقًا ، كل شيء جيد يا رجل ،
لذا يمكنك فقط وضع يديك على
السطح من أجلي ،
وسأقوم بإزالة بندقيتك ، حسنًا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نعم ، دعنا نمضي قدمًا ونخلع سترتك يا
رجل
[موسيقى
] أشم رائحة الكحول القادمة من أنفاسك
، هل مسموح لك بأداء
تمارين في الوسط أو تمارين الجسم ،
فأنت على
حق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هل فعلت أي شيء  للاحتفال اليوم
يا رجل آه لا يا سيدي ، لا
استمع يا رجل
، بل من الأفضل أن أكون صادقًا ،
فأنا لست محترفًا ،
فأنا أحب أم
بن أندرو ، استمع في مهنتنا ، فأنت
تعلم أنه من الأفضل أن أكون صادقًا بشكل صحيح
[موسيقى]
أنا أتوسل حقًا  أنت
لا أريد أن أذهب إلى السجن جيدًا ،
سنقدم لك الشكر
وسنكتشف ذلك ، حسنًا ،
ضع يديك على إطارك ، نعم